- As a museum,
we try to represent the entire
span of all life on Earth
and that's what a big
collection like ours is
basically there for.
My name is Jochen Gerber.
I am the Field Museum's
Invertebrates Collection Manager.
And today we are unboxing
a deep sea giant isopod.
A deep sea giant isopod
is basically a roly-poly
like the little things that
you find in your backyard
under a board or something like that.
Just, it's much much bigger so it's giant,
and it lives in the marine
realms in depths between
about three hundred and
eight hundred meters.
They are scavengers, so they eat mostly
dead stuff that they find.
Fish, dead crustaceans,
dead cephalopods, squid,
and so on, even dead whales.
This is about as big as this species gets,
about a foot long.
They are not on the endangered
species list right now but,
we preserve them in alcohol
because that allows us,
even after hundreds of years,
to study their anatomy,
where they came from,
what they are related to,
where they sit in the
tree of life so to speak.
This particular specimen has
not come out of the jar for
at least twenty years I would say.
The preserving is done mostly by the
by the collector because
you have to preserve them
right away basically.
You can't put them in your
suitcase and ship them through
three airports for three days,
then you have a very
badly preserved specimen.
So they should go into alcohol
pretty much right away.
Often, when I show these to the public,
they are reminded of the movie "Alien".
There is apparently a video,
where one of these guys
was together with a kind
of shark in a trap and
in these confined circumstances,
this thing could actually
latch onto the face of the
shark and started eating it,
so that's scary, but as I
said, there's really no reason
to be afraid of these.
It has a bit of the
smell of a dried shrimp,
or something like that, that
you would put in Korean soup.
I suppose it's an acquired taste.